this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Jacob so myself will be
focused on genetic architecture of
cyanide in cassava
so generally most plant species liberate
hydrogen cyanide from cyanogenic
glucoside and this process is known as
Lana Genesis Selena marine and Lotus
Raeleen are the two variants of
cyanogenic leukocytes in cassava and
these are bioactive a stable plant
secondary metabolites that provide
effective defense against hobby balls
for those plant now over the years they
have also taken up or rather evolved to
take up additional responsibility of
providing plant plasticity and also
specifically in cassava cyanogenic
glucoside is synthesized in the leaf and
transported to the root and usually our
partition between the peel of cassava
and the parenchyma now looking at
specifically cassava with respect to
cyanide now cassava as we all know
cassava is an important economic and
subsystem crop and it produced
efficiently under sub optimal condition
and among many challenges that cassava
as a crop has assisted food is that it
has a high thermogenic
leukocyte and in the past our colleagues
have walked on the biosynthesis pathway
for Sano Jinnah glucoside
in cassava now one thing to take note of
is that hg n which is an acid trace of
cyanide in cassava is a major
domestication trade now within cassava
breeding program and also food products
they usually use a simple diagnostic
test which is called pykrete
test to assay for for personalizing
cassava and it contains ten shades of
color charts are ranging from yellow
to brown and they represent cyanide
content in cassava in milligram now
specifically cassava is kind of
categorized into two you have the sweet
cassava and the bitter cassava and this
sweet and bitter cassava are also seen
as those having low cyanide and - I now
to consume cassava especially in South
Africa there are a couple of traditional
method of because scientist about
cyanide to get it to a level that is
safe for consumption what health level I
mean what held recommendation is 10 ppm
but some countries are Ivan you know
recommending lower than that but I
thought this this leaf is not specific
to any country but this is what this
part is across across southern Africa to
to reduce the sunnat' of cassava before
consuming it and I have a picture of a
woman that is roasting cassava so
basically you great along with pressing
and roasting but in addition you can
also soak some dry you can wet or heat
fermentation now any of these processes
would ordinarily if fuller strictly
reduce cyanide content of cassava but
oftentimes they don't follow it away so
cyanide poisoning still exists it might
not be in the extreme case in most cases
but you can see how other extreme cases
now we respect to how cassava is an
important staple in sub-saharan Africa
if you look at what production of
cassava you see that over 50 percent of
that production is coming from Africa
now this this now this does ensure that
you know we have to kind of tackle the
challenges that are associated with
cyanide in cassava so one of those
challenges is cyanide intoxication and
this happens usually
during agricultural crisis and happen
mostly within the region where you find
forests you know the poor people living
in rural area and what happened is that
during this agricultural crisis they
consume a lot of cassava consistent on
daily basis without successfully because
they find it but this leads to fan
identification based on individual
accessibility and the cyanide
intoxication is called kun zoo as a
neurological disease that is
irreversible and causes permanent
paralysis of the lower limb it was first
reported about eight decades ago for
example in Cambodia in 2002 about
100,000 cases was reported and I showed
a blood picture that depicts the
severity of disciplines of disease and
you can see in the severe case you end
up being permanently paralyzed now if
they resulted in couple of countries
within South Island Africa the most
recent is in Zambia between 2012 and
2015
about 40 cases have been reported now
I'm looking at this from the perspective
of future projection you will see that
what Food Program a prediction of food
insecurity as a result of climate change
is going to hit smooth in Africa and
that means there will be reduced use of
generally crop youth and that means
people would you know depend more on a
crop like a Saba but for subsistence so
in view of this what I try to do in this
study is to understand the architecture
and map the chin from breeding
perspective more or less providing a
tool or a Diagnostics that breeders can
use to bridge for the street now in this
study we're kind of collaborating with
my photographer reading program in
Brazil and we have access to over three
thousand five
and racism modern breeding lines coming
from you know the 26 states of Brazil
and that we have six trials I was done
in 2016 2017 2018 and 2019 and so we
came up with a schema for analysis about
to process the genetic data as well as
do a phenotypic analysis and use me
smaller to do it she was also we looked
at the phenotypic distribution and also
estimated variance component as well as
heritability now one thing to take home
here is that for this data set that
we're looking at from Brazil the
heritability is high and it tells us
that the stress will would have high
response to selection in Brazil now with
this gos and this was the results we got
for the Chile's we we found we got two
peaks one and chromosome 14 I want in
chromosome 16 and that is explaining the
regulation the variance that we see in
our data set and and so it's safe to say
that the hessian in this dataset is
regulated in an oligo Janique manner so
going forward we looked at the math
effect of candidates markers or candida
sniffs both focus on 14 and chromosome
16 another chromosome 14 shows additive
response why that aluminum 16 shows
dominance response and so listed below
is the number of individuals in each of
the genotypic categories but again
looking at the responses it is safe to
say that that this particular trait can
be bright using a simple a brilliant
strategy within the breeding program I
also estimated variance explained across
the genome but across also sub genomes
of interest specifically chromosome 16
explained 50% of variance in our data
says while candidates knitting
chromosome 16 explained 30 percent of
the variation in our data set
HCN my very forward we went back to
literature to check since the
biosynthesis pathway for this personage
any glucoside is been reported in the
past so we looked at the geometric
disrepair and the schematic you know
diagram of the Basking turkish gene
cluster and that the arrow is showing
the functional genes and their direction
is issuing the orientation of the chain
and this was done in cassava draft
genome fashioned for so we took those
genes and we map them to our fashion fix
of cassava genome that is used the
process by genotyping data so it's not
that those genes that are actually in
chromosome 12 so not in any of those
region that we found pigs corporation so
we did with it genome-wide epistasis
interaction and we actually did about
400 million tests across the genome
however we found no inter chromosomal
interaction across the genome for this
trait now just a brief just some
takeaways so far for the things I've
shown I've shown that happiness
irritability and that of genotypically
basis is 0.74 and 0.41 and then that the
regulation is responding in oligogenic
manner and there are two peaks are one
increment of 14 one in chromosome 16 and
they are explained in 16 percent and 50
percent aberration respectively from
zone 14 shows a bit leaf pattern
understand 7 percent wider of 16 shows a
dominant pattern unexplained 30 percent
of genetic variation now also we have no
evidence based on these data sets where
the species interaction are going
forward we did a couple of complimentary
analysis the map are the gene that is
responsible for the variation and this
is just a summary table specifically in
in the in the column where I have
the the healthy interval for chromosome
16 we have 16th Y chromosome 14 we have
three genes and I found religion based
on optimal p-value and a mutation
prediction is a transfer ties between an
anesthetist protein in 14 and their
standard a snips are found within the
coding region of those candidate genes
now I had initially described a
situation in Africa but we started with
Brazilian data and the reasoning that
acaba originated from Brazil and was
also domesticated in it was transferred
to to Africa but they were additional
improvement I was done that changed the
genome last year so the idea was in
landfill in Brazil and then apply that
knowledge to Africa we went to the
Ferger base and found lots of try about
300 might be three trials that was done
across 23 years and we use this virtuous
or this trait we've used on unity big
distribution and its method of area as
well as a heritability and one thing we
observe in this case is that the genetic
variance a variation is low but that if
we did the GOS analysis we also found
two peaks one in 14 and one in 16 if
you're aligned is with the previous data
size coming from Brazil you see that
they properly aligned so it's safe to
say that at least based on this data set
the genetic architecture comes up we
also did joint u.s. analysis we found
the same peak and even in this case the
candidates are we're separated from the
rest of the snips and we also aligned it
with the previous dual result it's
Alliance are probably so just to just
summarize the results for this data set
we saw that the phenotypic variability
varies across you know the two data sets
and healthy and is conducting both
dataset HC&S your belated in an
illegitimate manner we found no evidence
based on this data set that there is a
stasis interruption and so since we
define any peak in chromosomes
where we found those genes that we tend
to speculate that perhaps domestication
of cassava targeted upstream or
downstream genetic regulation steps of
HCN biosynthesis so one of the
deliverables is to there's a lot of
stuff for my house that is available to
the community for breeders to use of
breeding diagnostic nests test I will be
to do functional characterization
knockout validation of the diagnostic
market and Africa as well as as well as
expression studies run long term I want
to look at the impact of climate change
and cyanide and also to develop
materials that can be deployed to this
cyanide intoxication how sports in
sub-saharan Africa that's what wouldn't
have been possible without a lot of
people specifically I want to thank my
comic salute actually a Susan and
generous but also breeding program in
Reseda which led by EDA
and as our collaborators in Africa and
it's my Rabi we're doing the web
presentation the marketers we develop I
also want to appreciate me girl we're
working with the lab to functionally
validate our high-beam I was
appreciative Oaks and Muller lab
especially DM
whom was always available to answer my
question and what that means that's what
I've been is initially when he was a
pilot for now often time I accidentally
school question and he was generous to
answer that I want to thank BPI from our
past and plant breeding thank you a big
question thank you very much Alex I
think I'll have a bit of time for a
couple of questions and buckler's has
nice thoughts outs to that he was speaks
overlap with diversity sweep seen in the
hapmap and does the biosynthetic cluster
on crimson twelve have little diversity
according to a map yeah so if I get the
question arises so we we so we might
both musician I lives within the half
we also did a whole genome institution
using the hapmap as a reference for that
particular our chromosome 16 and we
found the same the same result we we
found the same region and the same
sneak-attack candidates me if if I
answer a question okay Kristen asks
thanks Alex do you have a sense for how
decreasing cyanide contents may impact
test resistance and therefore
potentially yield so yeah they've been
that this question always comes up I
didn't I didn't look at this
specifically but what I try to do here
is to understand the genetic
architecture to have this knowledge or
information would be used for that to do
specific studies and how it does affect
that previous I've seen about one or two
studies that was done previously in ICA
and it doesn't show that that is the
case but this is this is open for
further studies but but we respected is
I'm just looking at the architecture of
famine okay well thank you very much
Alex I think we'll move on to our third
speaker now
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu